uh but over the weekend we learned who
the real idiots are and it should come
as no surprise
they're members of the so-called
mainstream press which is really just
the left-wing press
specifically reporters like maggie
haberman of the new york times and ellen
nagashima of the washington post you may
recognize those names
they've been investigating president
trump's russia ties
for years but over the weekend they
suffered quite a setback
and were forced to retract their latest
fake news bombshell
claiming that the fbi warned giuliani
he was a russian pawn now nobody
seriously believed that story anyway
it always had the hallmarks of a deep
state deep fake
citing people familiar with the matter
current and former u.s officials and one
of our favorites
in american official
i can't think of anything less specific
i'm sure a good journalist protects his
or her sources
but they also check facts that clearly
did not happen
in this case as with many others and
when that bombshell
fell in their laps they bought it hook
line and sinker
they didn't ask questions and they
disseminated that disinformation that
was provided to them
to millions of people around the world
just as intended
because to the deep state these
so-called journalists
are the most useful idiots of all
joining me now pulitzer prize winning
journalist
glenn greenwald glenn do these things
surprise you at all
anymore
no and not anymore they don't i mean
obviously any journalist who works for a
long time is going to get stories wrong
that's normal you make a prompt
correction and then you move on but
what's happening here is completely
different
they're using the same tactics over and
over that continuously
result in false fake reporting
how is it there are three different
outlets that reported the same false
story washington post
nbc and new york times how is it that
they all
independently confirm the same false
story something they've been doing over
and over for years
it's because they're not really
reporting they're going to the same
people buried in the cia and the fbi who
are telling them what to say
they don't investigate it they don't
subject it to any critical scrutiny they
just
blare it in headlines three this truth
and
they're acting as stenographers for the
security state and not
actual journalists and over and over
they get caught doing it they have to
retract stories
apologize admit they spread fake news
but because they don't have any interest
in doing true reporting
they keep doing the same thing over and
over stenographers
for the state what a perfect way to put
it i mean you remember the the the
absolute boasting that came along with
the misinformation around the iran deal
yet it continues it happened to
president donald trump it's still
happening now
what if anything can be done will these
newsrooms ever step back and say
maybe your sources aren't quite what
they should be maybe you're pursuing an
agenda why haven't you written a story
from the other perspective does that
ever happen
or is the group think just too strong to
the left in all of these newsrooms
well i think what's happening is their
their uh journalistic malfeasance is
becoming so glaring that
they're even now part of them are
starting to acknowledge it cnn published
a story calling this a huge black eye
for these outlets that's cnn that has
many of their own black eyes doing the
same thing and what really is happening
is that
there's now this you know independent
uh dissent that's arising on independent
platforms obviously [ __ ] new fox news
criticizes them as well and what is
their solution it's not to say
let's get better it's to silence people
who are their critics to censor them
from the internet to get them kicked off
cable
on the grounds that those other people
are spreading disinformation
when the most prolific and aggressive
spreaders of disinformation are they
themselves or they just admit
as some have recently listened some
sides are more worth reporting than
others so we're just going to report
that one side because we're the arbiters
of what's good and what isn't glenn
readwell thank you for being the
exception to the rule we appreciate it i
always love having you
thanks for having me you got it hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else